moving on to some developing news this
hour uh
perdue farmer this is the maker of
oxycontin will face charges for their
role in the u.s
opioid epidemic this is according to
justice department officials
oxycontin it is a powerful prescription
painkiller
government officials said purdue palmer
farmer will plead guilty to three
federal criminal charges
as part of a settlement of more than
eight billion dollars not
it is the biggest result i should say
from a u.s government investigation into
the country's opioid crisis
which is linked to nearly half a million
deaths
uh while we wait to hear from the
department of justice we'll talk to
shihab ratanzi our correspondent
following this one in in washington d.c
uh if this all comes out as we expect
she have this will be a very significant
development
significant on in both sort of a
negative and positive way perhaps you
could say what we're just getting the
details now from the department of
justice
8.34 billion dollar settlement which
will resolve this
year-long criminal civil probe by the
justice department
that eight point three billion point
eight point three four billion dollar
number
is relatively symbolic though because
purdue farmer doesn't
doesn't even have that money so in the
short term actually they're likely to
pay around 225 million dollars to the
government
with the sackler family this is the the
family that that owned purdue farmer
that made a huge amount of fortune out
of
of selling opioids a name that you will
often see on you know museums and
cultural institutions around the world
they're going to give about 225 million
dollars to resolve civil claims
purdue farmer pleading guilty to three
charges
uh including conspiracy to defraud the
us
violating federal anti-kickback laws
basically what they're admitting to is
that they
they didn't despite telling the federal
drug administration that they had
an effective red flag system to avoid
the drug being diverted to places where
it shouldn't be
they actually didn't have any such thing
not only that they were paying doctors
to write more prescriptions they were
conspiring to dispense opioids without
any legitimate medical
purpose which is sort of fueled the
enormous opioid crisis
in the united states so we're still
getting
those details but but what's also key is
that purdue farmer will still exist
after this settlement although as a a a
company held in trust for the benefit of
american society theoretically that is
there will be a trust board that will
decide
the interest of the company versus the
interest of the american people
but purdue farmer itself will still
continue researching
selling opioids to the american people
shihab i feel
like pretty much anything in the u.s
right now can be viewed through the
prism of the election in
two weeks time can you put this one into
that context for us the
the idea of the department of justice
pushing this through now exactly this
was a major trump campaign promise
before he was elected that he would
address the opioid crisis a particular
issue in
the hardcore trump states of the united
states
uh in rural areas but also you know in
cities and elsewhere but this is a way
then that if they've come
if they've come to this conclusion they
can say mission accomplished another
trump election promise
from the last election uh has been
brought you know to fruition
vote trump the problem with all this is
partly in what i was saying a moment ago
that
about 25 states including dc and dc have
have said look we don't want this we
don't want this settlement for various
reasons it lets
purdue farmer and the sackler family off
too easily
these are you know you know
multi-billionaires they might lose a few
you know millionaire dollars here and
there no criminal charges against the
executives
who did so much damage to people in in
the united states
having purdue pharma still exists even
as this kind of public trust
is is a little bizarre they say that
means then that
that a certain amount of the money from
purdue pharma will go into
mediation efforts mitigation efforts for
opioids and
a lot of attorney general say we're
uncomfortable about selling more
oxycontin in order to help people with
oxycontin they don't like that that idea
but in the end this is about
accountability
are the people responsible really being
held accountable through all of this
or is this just a few numbers on a
spreadsheet
and purdue farmer just gets away with it
shia britannia with that update from
washington
thank you shihab